dans le métier stéphane genêt et sojitz
heures autrement dit fumeurs de harengs
dans la réalité c'est un spécialiste du
souvent saumon écossais label rouge
saumon irlandais bio et sommant de
france aussi cet ancien restaurateur n'a
pas son pareil pour fumer les poissons
et décliner ses produits
on a toute la petite gamme de marine et
donc on fait le classique le petit
marais d alan est ce assez les bases
huile d'olive
mais rossi boulette le petit gingembre
on a les petits marine à la menthe ou
six ans qu'il est pour les apéritifs les
petites salades ont fait aussi également
après les fêtes on va attaquer en fait c
selon marie leoz algues qu'on travaille
avec un petit fournisseur qu'on a en
bretagne moi je fonctionne beaucoup en
bouche à oreille et puis de noël en noël
sas a grandi et puis voilà donc une
bonne petite clientèle locale nous
jouerons à peu près à 50 kilomètres à la
ronde
mais pourquoi ça tue
stéphane gêné adoptant le souligne qu'il
est parvenu à se faire un an
depuis une dizaine d'années dans des
produits haut de gamme
tout est travaillé à la main c'est du
fait maison
un marché de niche
j'essaye de faire des tranches à peu
près de 50 grammes puis on veut de la
tranche grosse au niveau du poids va
plus on va incliné sur le fil est on est
restés nous sur l'audience
on se différencier aussi de la grande
distribution l'agroalimentaire nontron
part de la bête entière
donc les filets sont levés à la main des
arrêtés à la main on sale avec un sel
sec pour peut non pas l'injonction de
saumur après c'est un fumoir
traditionnel noir à la sueur de l'être
avec un tirage naturel
la sonnerie du gâtinais fait dans
d'autres produits nobles également pour
preuve ces coquilles saint-jacques fumée
c'est donc ton et marlin
on va être fumé
noël et le nouvel an période charnière
pour l'activité de cette petite
entreprise familiale de tonnes de
semences ont traité sur les cinq qui
arrivent ici chacun